I mean hey you guys hey hey six-time
Grammy nominee hey Bill amazing this
cowboy fit a sweet day with everything
going on but you know I'm keeping the
energy positive you both posted about
Kobe and if you each want to share your
thoughts on how you're feeling he's
obviously a top of mind for everybody
tonight
yeah I'm is just extremely unexpected
and sad and like you know Kobe goes
beyond just basketball and he's like an
icon a legend overall and um no I hate I
hate did that happen yeah your daddy too
and so I mean thinking about his
daughter with him him you can probably
tell I'm a little swollen I when I'm not
on camera I'm crying and my whole family
is we just I just can't stop crying and
even to think of it and Kobe was such a
great man living oz said it best not
only was he a legend in sports but he
was a legend as a man as a father and
just a great role model and it's a it's
a very sad tragic day and bittersweet
for all of us here at the Grammys you
know how the Grammys is going to honor
him tonight have you heard anything
about how they're they're gonna honor
him on the show I'm sure they're going
to deuce or say something I know I got a
little something I wrote on my guitar I
have a little Kobe going out with me on
stage tonight and you know being here
again we're in the center of Los Angeles
it's hard even though that Los Angeles
has had so many greats it's hard to rank
up to the top with Kobe Bryant I mean
it's just a tremendous loss and his
daughter his daughter and an end and
just it's it's just heartbreaking
Luna's can you can describe this year
what it's been can you even describe
like your life this year and for you to
have come out this year and to be in the
place you're in now six Grammy
nominations how do you feel waking up
this morning and thinking about what
you've done I just feel like this year
like last year and even like the
beginning of this here has been so much
growth like beyond just you know the
fame and fortune like mentally
spiritually I've grown so much how broad
are you Billy Ray I'm proud of this guy
right here part of this he had a vision
you know he he took some walls down and
it wasn't living you know inside the box
outside the box thinking like there was
no box
this guy's a game changer and he's
changed the game of music forever I saw
you you guys in Keith Urban at CMA fest
this year you killed the stage so what
are you gonna do tonight you want to
talk to you about trailblazers I mean oh
someone grabbed my body oh well Billy
Ray you're a desirable man you want to
talk trailblazers your daughter Miley I
for her recent music has just been
unbelievable can you talk about how
proud you are of the journey she's been
on I was talking to somebody who does
music with her they were like she's just
raw Ryan Tedder he says she's just real
with a man let's just tell you man wait
till you hit this new song she's getting
ready to break out whether it's just
gonna blow your mind
like she has hit full stride Noah has
hit closer eyed she's got one of the
hottest records on the radio with July
and man it's just blowing up so for all
the girls and my boys everybody just its
music changes everything it really does
and when you harness music with your
heart here so that's what musics all
about last question I know you know
you're the dad she looks up to you how
do you feel about Cody as he welcomed
and the family approved of he's an
incredible young man and he's a great
musician he's also a great swimmer I
don't know if you know but he's probably
gonna be on the US Olympic team I don't
know that for sure
[Applause]
Wow
thank you so much to the fans everybody
who supported this collaboration that is
just went on its own journey Thank You
Billy Ray Cyrus thank you so my dad my
sister my brothers yeah everybody thank
you I'll thank the fans this really was
the fans record the fans made this thing
go all around the world they embraced it
and made it their own and being here
again on this day I'm gonna accept this
one in the name and honor of Kobe Bryant
you all deserve this have a hell of a
time tonight okay
[Music]